special counsel is now in charge of
investigating Russian interference with
the last presidential election the
Justice Department appointed former FBI
director robert muller yesterday with
almost no warning he will take over
where the bureau's investigation left
off that could lead to more trouble for
the Trump administration Robert Muller
led the FBI for 12 years longer than
anyone but J Edgar Hoover he was named
as special counsel one day after we
learn of a memo by fired FBI director
James Comey Comey claims that President
Trump asked him to stop an investigation
a former national security adviser
Michael Flynn Jeff Pegues is at the
Justice Department Jeff good morning
good morning and that memo was really a
turning point that pushed DOJ to make
this move bringing in Robert Muller
really changes things he is the former
FBI director and he is highly regarded
in Washington by both Democrats and
Republicans as special counsel he will
have the power to prosecute if crimes
were committed
all right Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosen Stein says in a statement the
special counsel will ensure a full and
thorough investigation of the Russian
government's efforts to interfere in the
2016 presidential election it was Rosen
Stein's mood since Attorney General Jeff
Sessions recused himself from all Russia
related investigations over his own
contacts with the Russian ambassador but
sessions did play a role in former FBI
director James Comey is firing last week
President Trump was said to be measured
in his response to Robert Muller's
appointment as he huddled with his
senior staff in the Oval Office the
White House then released a statement
saying there was no collusion between my
campaign and any foreign entity I look
forward to this matter concluding
quickly on Tuesday it was revealed Comey
drafted a memo after a private oval
office meeting with President Trump on
February 14th then director Comey wrote
how President Trump tried to convince
him to drop the federal investigation I
hope you can see your way clear to
letting this go to letting Flynn go the
president allegedly said he is a good
guy I hope you can let this go
meeting with President Trump came one
day after lieutenant general Flynn was
forced to resign his post as national
security advisor after Flynn misled the
vice president about his contacts with
Russian ambassador Sergei Kiss lyac Kiss
lyac who met with the president last
week is a central figure in the FBI
investigation Muller who resigned from
private practice for this appointment
wrote I accept this responsibility and
will discharge it to the best of my
ability he served as FBI director for a
dozen years starting a week before the
9/11 attacks before that he led the u.s.
probe into the 1988 Pan Am 103 bombing
at the time it was the deadliest
terrorist attack against Americans you
want to know who ordered it and you want
to know who approved it and who else was
involved in carrying out the attack
Muller has been promised resources in
this investigation to follow leads even
the resources of the FBI he has also
been given broad authority to chase
those leads wherever they may go
gaile all right thank you Jeff